[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver dans le 7-8 loisirs vos idées
sorties dans le département on commence
ensuite avec le sommaire de ce numéro le
centre alfred de vigny fait sa rentrée
2010 est en musique les pétillantes un
groupe de quatre pianistes se produira
samedi soir nous recevrons la
coordinatrice du centre pour nous en
parler
la danse urbaine s'invite au prisme
d'elancourt danse des guerriers de la
ville une exposition sur le hip hop et
ludique et interactive reportage à
suivre
enfin dans notre rendez-vous junior il
sera question de légumes avec mélanie
poker elle nous présentera le jeu de
société top chrono créé par une
habitante de bois d'arcy et on commence
par du sport avec un match important ce
week end le premier de l'année 2010 est
pour le rugby club de versailles
pour cette 10e journée du championnat
ile de france honneur les seniors
affronteront manque lui mais au stade
parc fontaine
un match qui s'annonce serré les
précisions du président du club
c'est un début de reprise qui est très
très important puisque finalement
versailles qui est 4e aujourd'hui
rencontre ce dimanche menti mec est
premier ex-aequo et le dimanche d'après
il rencontre bagneux qui est l'autre
premier ex-aequo à l'enjeu est l'enjeu
capital et ça va se jouer au mental
une idée de sortie théâtre à maurepas
depuis le début du mois de janvier
chaque samedi mais public est invité à
découvrir les troupes amateur local
ce samedi c'est la troupe du crâne qui
sera sur la scène de l'espace albert
camus les comédiens présenteront des
contes pour les petits et des grands
enfants la belle et la bête le petit
chaperon rouge et le théâtre d'arlequin
on écoute la metteuse en scène au micro
de mélanie poquet c'est la première fois
que je touche aux comptes et c'est un
enchantement vraiment d'abord d'aider il
n'y a pas
et y'a pas de théâtre bâtard tout est
beau à monter il faut un peu d'
imaginaires garder un petit peu une âme
d'enfant surtout je crois la bobine sera
j'ai préparé un galet pour ta grand-mère
et j'aimerais que tu la vie apporte avec
ce petit pot de beurre et je vous le
disais le centre alfred de vigny débute
2010 est en musique avec un spectacle
celui des pétillante céline sylvia
vicence nous a rejoint en plateau est la
coordinatrice du centre bonjour céline
alors un mot sur ce spectacle qui a lieu
samedi soir à 20h30 un concert spectacle
plus précisément qui sont les
pétillantes alors les pétillantes elles
sont quatre donc alors coignard isabelle
lévesque
nathalie frei et j'oublie personnes
caroline carvennec elle vaches à elles
ont deux invités 7,7
parce que c'est un nouveau spectacle en
fait chaque fois les pétillantes fondées
heureusement les classiques bien sûr
mais introduisent du théâtre et un
humour assez décapant donc vous verrez
ça me dit si vous revenez me voir sont
des pianistes en fait elle mêle elles
ont elles sont quatre donc elles se sont
elles mais le piano à quatre mains et à
huit manches tout à fait elle le joue
donc des morceaux de boléro de ravel du
classique complètement et elles partent
un petit peu dégoûté sur des saynètes
sur un morceau
elles vont elles vont faire une
interprétation et c'est assez surprenant
et très intéressante alors mentionné
comme je le veux je disais elles ont
invité donc une chanteuse de musique du
monde qui va présenter un instrument
magique
j'ai entendu les répète c'est le nickel
et repasse est un instrument norvégien
donc c'est vraiment particulier et un
percussionniste et guitariste qui
s'appelle jean marie des miens et pour
la la chanteuse de musique du monde
c'est katie green chili donc ils vont
participer au spectacle agrémenté et
donner une autre tonalité par rapport à
ce qu'on connaissait des pétillante
puisqu'elle commence un petit peu a
tourné dans les environs alors je les ai
je vous ai même fait jouer à rebondir ce
que vous disiez ne fait que c'est un
spectacle qui mêle humour et piano je
pense que le mieux en fait pour s'en
rendre compte tout simplement de
regarder il vous propose de voir un
extrait on se retrouve tout de suite
après
[Musique]
alors vous l'avez peut-être reconnu
c'était bien sur le lac des cygnes un
grand classique
alors comment est ce que vous avez connu
les pétillantes et pourquoi avoir voulu
les invités ce samedi
alors elle tend déjà joué plusieurs fois
chez nous elles ont participé aussi à
des formats on faisait des dégustations
et du spectacle classique c'est à dire
il mettait en scène à un son une
tonalité et une dégustation
donc elles sont très dans l'impro aussi
c'est très intéressant leur travail et
donc isabelle avec qui on collabore
aussi et enseignante au centre alfred de
vigny de musique et de piano classique
c'est tout dit qu'ils s'en fassent
vraiment à tout le monde tout public
voilà on a un tarif pour les adultes et
un tarif pour les enfants
ça démarre à 20h30 et j'invite vraiment
les gens ceux qui les connaissent à
venir parce que c'est complètement
différent et ceux qui les connaissent
pas vont être ravis tout public vraiment
peut savourer cet instant et de musique
et d'humour
on va voir un tout peu plus loin cette
fois ci la semaine prochaine samedi au
21 janvier sur les autres animations à
venir alors on change totalement
d'univers parce que cette fois ci c'est
warhammer alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas forcément ça un jeu de
rôle un jeu de figurines en fait écrit
qui a été créée dans les années 80 avec
un univers d'heroic fantasy est un peu à
la seigneur des anneaux c'est un
rassemblement du coup que vous organisez
est-ce que ça s'adresse qu'aux fans ou
est ce que c'est vraiment pour tout le
monde pour tous les curieux qu est ce
qui lui aura sur cette journée alors cet
événement c'est la huitième
8e édition c'est un rassemblement
warhammer donc sa robe ça reprend tout
ces univers quand vous disiez du
seigneur des anneaux ou war machine à
d'autres univers qui font partie de ce
monde là de l'ars oi et donc c'est de
10h30 à 18h30 le samedi 21 janvier ça
s'adresse à tous puisqu'il va y avoir
des parties d'initiation de découvert
des partis pro entre guillemets pour
ceux qui vont qui vont jouer en direct
live avec avec vous et puis un atelier
de peinture sur figurines aussi parce
que cet univers là c'est vraiment des
petites figurines des choses très
méticuleuse et il ya tout un vraiment un
univers à découvrir donc c'est entrée
libre
tout le monde peut venir grand petit
essai est mené par des jeunes du club
qui initie tous les samedis cet univers
et qui vont organiser cet événement pour
le faire découvrir au plus grand nombre
au centre allemande mêmes même si on
connaît pas c'est un événement à venir
découvrir les choses préfet merci
beaucoup à sylvia votre venue sur notre
plateau pour nous parler de ces deux
événements on le rappelle le concert des
pétillante aura lieu demain soir au
centre alfred de vigny toutes les
informations à retrouver sur le site
internet merci beaucoup c'est ling et
parlons danse à présent et plus
précisément hip hop jusqu'à demain le
prisme vous invite à découvrir cette
danse autour d'une exposition
interactive une expérience sensorielle
et ludique mené grâce à des
installations vidéos reportages de
freestyle ou bâle ceux des termes qui
vous sont peut être inconnu si vous
ignorez tout de l'univers du peuple avec
ce parcours immersif et participatif
le prisme et la compagnie par terre
propose une découverte en images les
visiteurs entre 10 mai vont
danser et rendre vivante
l'exposition donc voilà c'est des
petites installations et à chaque
installation il ya un jeu à faire une
consigne un déguisement un pas et voilà
même si on sait pas danser finalement on
arrive à expérimenter la danse en tout
cas c'est hyper encadrer et accompagner
avec les nouvelles technologies
parmi les outils présentés une machette
et bol pour devenir le chorégraphe d'une
battle conçu par la braqueuse nguyen
danse des guerriers de la ville c'est
aussi un tour des différents styles et
mouvements de hip hop dans les années
soixante dix il ya eu les danses dites
old school de l'ancienne école donc qui
ont émergé sur les cours en fac pour les
danses dites debout donc il ya le pop
donc tout ce qui est contractions
musculaires et le lock qui est plus
issus de tous les laits les fonds qui
step de l'époque et le break le break
c'est la danse au sol et donc les
musiques ont traversé le temps ont
changé et ça à chaque musique finalement
le les mêmes bases sont là mais
interprétés différemment
en parallèle du parcours des ateliers
sont proposés aux visiteurs pour une
initiation avec l'un des guerriers de la
ville la breakdance et le locking
n'auront plus de secrets
et on retrouve mélanie poker pour notre
rendez-vous junior bonjour mélanie vous
allez nous parler d'enjeux de société
c'est un jeu de société un jeu imaginé
et conçu pas très long de 51 ans n'est
lui emilie thomas la créatrice vis à
bois d'arcy alors le jeu s'appelle top
chrono
c'est un jeu de plateau type jeu de
l'oie pour se rendre plus compte
les joueurs sont des petits tops qui
cherchent à manger correctement et
surtout à voler la récolte dans le
potager de ma de monsieur topinambours
et je vous propose d'écouter la
créatrice
l'idée est venue en fait donc je suis
infirmière de profession et je vais
travailler en service de pédiatrie ans
fils de rééducation et je prenais en
charge des enfants en surcharge
pondérale et l'idée est née à partir de
cette expérience professionnelle où
j'avais noté effectivement une
méconnaissance
des enfants concernant l'alimentation
générale et concernant les légumes en
particulier
alors comment est ce qu'on y jouer ni
quelles sont les règles alors les règles
d'abord ça se joue de deux à six joueurs
vous êtes donc des petits tops je le
disais hé vous choisi ces trois légumes
à voler parmi tous ceux proposés vous
lancer le dé et bien sûr vous avancez du
nombre de cases demandé comme chaque jeu
il ya des petites cases particulière des
passes ton tour des quatre chances et
des petites questions pour progresser
d'ailleurs je voudrais vous faire un
petit test qu'à lui on va en profiter
à la première question à défaut de canne
à sucre de canne à sucre
on peut fabriquer du sucre avec du
potiron de la betterave ou du navet de
la betterave notamment jugé bon c'est ça
vous pourriez avancée des ukases
deuxième question là c'est un peu plus
dur lequel laquelle de ces personnes a
réellement existé lecomte d'artichaut le
baron d'oignons ou la reine d'aspect
c'est déjà plus un piège quand même
j'irai le comte d'artichaut dawson ou
bien sympathique et le bar en donnions
alors il s'appelle artus de la fontaine
solara il était maître de conférences de
cérémonie sous lé règne d'henri 2
françois 1er charlot 9 et henri ii aussi
de par mon épouse et moi j'ai fait des
petites anecdotes c'est à lui selon
l'histoire à qui on devrait l'expression
se mettre en rang d'oignons alors on
revient au jeu c'était la petite
parenthèse celui qui gagne la partie
c'est celui qui a réussi à voler ces
trois légumes choisi au début du jeu
alors faut savoir qu'une partie dure
entre 15 et 20 minutes et emilie nous
explique cette fois à qui il s'adresse
j'adresse aux enfants à partir de 5 ans
en tout cas pour tout ce qui est de la
reconnaissance des légumes et un système
aussi de questions je comprends 275
carte questions réponses avec des
niveaux différents
justement pour permettre de faire jouer
les plus petits avec des questions plus
simple plus basique alors votre idée
pour occuper nos petits poussins ce week
end
où peut-on trouver ce jeu
il ya plusieurs moyens le site internet
qui va s'afficher en bas de l'écran
là vous allez dans la catégorie contact
et sur le site vous pouvez aussi
retrouver toutes les adresses des points
de vente y en a six dans les yvelines un
peu partout en france
il faut savoir que top chrono il coûte
20 9 euros 90 merci beaucoup mélanie
poquet pour cette découverte peut être
un moyen de faire aimer facilement les
légumes aux enfants aussi on sait jamais
en tout cas on passe maintenant à notre
agenda les rendez vous à ne pas manquer
ce week end en football se jouera les
seizièmes de finale de la coupe des
yvelines avec un choc un choc saint
quentinois villepreux en première
division de district recevra le club de
guyancourt une équipe d'excellence
guyancourt qui était allé jusqu'en demi
finales de la compétition la saison
dernière le professeur sébastien
mossière vous invite à son école de
magie mercredi prochain à plaisir petits
et grands aideront leurs enseignants un
peu loufoque qui a réalisé ces tours un
apprentissage avec une grande dose
d'humour et ce week-end mais terme
météo france annonçait quelques flocons
comme c'était le cas ce jeudi soir et
vendredi matin
peut-être l'occasion d'enfiler ses
moufles et faire des bonhommes de neige
c'est la fin de ce set 8 loisirs merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis je vous
retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end
[Musique]